Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to make the Mona Lisa and
other fictional characters come to life through
this DeepFake technology that is able to create
more detailed videos than previous techniques.
So, what are DeepFakes? Simple, we record a
video of ourselves, as you see me over here
doing just that, and with this, we can make
a different person speak. What you see here
is my favorite DeepFake application where
I became these movie characters and tried
to make them come alive. Ideally, expressions, eye
movements and other gestures are also transferred.
Some of them even work for animation movie
characters too. Absolutely lovely. This can
and will create filmmaking much more accessible
for all of us, which I absolutely love. Also,
when it comes to real people, just imagine how
cool it would be to create a more smiling version
of an actor without actually having to re-record
the scene. Or maybe even make legendary actors
appear in a new movie. The band Abba is already
doing these virtual concerts where they appear
as their younger selves, which is a true
triumph of technology. What a time to be alive!
Now, if you look at these results, these are
absolutely amazing, but the resolution of the
outputs is not the greatest. They don’t seem to
have enough fine details to look so convincing.
And here is where this new paper comes into play.
Now, hold on to your papers and have a look at
this. Wow. Oh my! Yes, you are seeing correctly,
the authors claim that these are the first one
megapixel resolution deepfakes out there. This
means that they showcase considerably more
detail than the previous ones. I love these,
the amount of detail compared to
previous works is simply stunning.
But, as you see, these are not perfect by any
means. There is a price to be paid for these
results. And the price is that we need to trade
some temporal coherence for these extra pixels.
What does that mean? It means that as
we move from one image to the next one,
the algorithm does not have a perfect memory of
what it had done before, and therefore some of
these jarring artifacts will appear. Now,
you are all experienced Fellow Scholars,
so here, you know that we have to invoke The
First Law Of Papers, which says that research
is a process. Do not look at where we are, look
at where we will be two more papers down the line.
So, megapixel results huh? How
long do we have to wait for these?
Well, if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper because these
somewhat reduced examples work in real time. This
means that we can point a camera at ourselves,
do our thing, and see ourselves become
these people on our screens in real time.
Now, I love the film directing
aspect of these videos, and also,
I am super excited for us to be able to even
put ourselves into a virtual world. And clearly,
there are also people who are less interested in
these amazing applications with these techniques.
To make sure that we are prepared
and everyone knows about this,
I am trying my best to teach political decision
makers from all around the world to make sure
that they can make the best decisions for
all of us. And I do this free of charge. As
any self-respecting Fellow Scholar would do,
you can see me holding on to my papers here
at a NATO conference. At such a conference, I
often tell these political decision makers that
DeepFake detectors also exist, how reliable
they are, what the key issues are, and more.
So, what do you think? What actor
or musician would you like to see
revived this way? Prince or Robin Williams
anyone? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!